Republican plan to repeal Obamacare has
cleared its first major hurdle President
Trump and the bill supporters celebrated
their victory in the White House Rose
Garden the house narrowly approved the
bill Democrats and many health care
providers denounced it the American
Health Care Act replaces Obamacare as
health insurance subsidies with an
age-based
tax credit to purchase coverage states
can ask for waivers so insurers can
charge higher premiums for people with
pre-existing conditions states would
have to set up high-risk pools to help
pay the cost the bill passed the house
nearly four months after mr. Trump told
The Washington Post we're going to have
have insurance for everybody it will be
a much simplified form much less
expensive and much better with us now is
dr. Robert pearl executive director and
CEO of the Permanente Medical Group he's
responsible for health care provided to
more than 11 million Kaiser Permanente
members Kaiser Permanente is one of the
nation's largest nonprofit healthcare
providers Pearl is also the author of
mistreated why we think we're getting
good health care and were usually wrong
dr. pearl good morning great to have you
here how do you see this bill out of the
House of Representatives it's just a
first step as Charlie said it has to
still go to the Senate where it's going
to invariably have significant changes
sitting in play they'll have to go to
conference committee this has a long way
to go before it's the law of the land
suppose the Senate would come to you and
say you're involved in health care tell
us what we need to do what's not in this
bill or what's in this bill it shouldn't
be pre-existing conditions is key we've
got to make sure we provide coverage to
those who are the sickest in this nation
we also have to make sure that health
care is affordable you can't get health
care if you can't pay the out-of-pocket
premiums you're not going to get that
care and then finally it's got to have
adequate coverage so when you go to the
doctor and things are done that it's
going to be paid through your program
and I'd say the last part is that's got
to be at the delivery system it's got to
be better organized forgive me because I
think this is important because there
are a number of Americans who have
pre-existing conditions who are really
worried and my understanding of this
House bill is that it would allow states
to do a waiver what does that mean for
someone who has something like diabetes
or cancer who has had
heart surgery well we don't know yet
because no one's done the waivers that's
the key part of the build I'm saying the
unknown piece of the bill is that we
don't know what's going to happen
through these waivers we could have 50
different bills each state could handle
it differently and it may be different
than New York that is New Jersey and
different than Connecticut than
California seems to be that there's a
lot of codes in this bill a lot that we
do not know what is it that we the
patient because at some point all of us
will be patients what is the thing that
we should be most worried about or
concerned about we have to make sure
that we maintain the coverage for all
the people who have it today we have to
make sure that you can have coverage
without having access if you can't
afford it so the the opportunity for
everyone to get the health care that
they have today is crucial to maintain
both for those with disease and all of
us at some point will get when does this
bill provide back to the account of the
house at this point I can't say because
of all the provisions that we don't know
and as I say also the fact that the
Senate's going to be there what's
interesting about this and even when
they voted on it they had not read the
bill because that had not had a chance
to prepare the bill correct I don't know
whether they read it or not but the the
bill is still in a work-in-progress
at some particular point after to the
efforts in the Senate so go to the
Common Committee
we're finally the bill will be putting
the final president and talking about
the Australian prime minister said they
have a better health care system than we
do so the question that I have is who
has the right health care system and
what should we try to create the most
important thing and we're not even
talking about yet is the care delivery
system all most of these bills are about
coverage who's going to pay how much
they're going to pay who's going to get
the ability to get the care but what's
key is the delivery system is care
integrated the physicians work together
as one horizontally within departments
and vertically between primary care and
specialty care of course this nation's
often no is it prepaid so it's not
driving a volume it's getting value
people are focusing on unnecessary desk
heavenly people die every year in this
country why they die for a combination
of failures of prevention they die
because of medical error my father died
for medical error that book you
mentioned it starts to the story of my
father and they died because the
disparities and outcomes based upon race
half a million people
you can't get the convenient care the
care all three of you want to get in
your travel and your banking can you go
online make it a point with your doctor
can you email could you video no you
accept so much less than your healthcare
than anywhere else we've got to change
that in the United States
they say that older Americans will see
higher premiums under this this proposed
bill is that true what you're describing
is the fact that under the Affordable
Care Act the maximum you can be charged
based on age is three times the lower
premium in the new bill it's five times
and then the waivers
no one knows a lot of choices no one
knows and what about mandating
preventive care services
that's the coverage piece absolutely if
we don't do the things that advance the
prevent disease then people just get
sick of the costs can arise over time
and over time the cost of health care
exceeds our ability to pay every
insurance plan you acknowledge that this
Republican plan and repealing and
replacing Obamacare puts more power in
the hands of insurers like you and out
of the government I think it puts more
power in under the states is where it's
going to be this is moving from the
federal one-size-fits-all to the
possibility at 50 different sizes coming
out of this particular plans it's so
hard dr. Pearle everybody says they want
good health care they want it to be less
expensive they want it to be inclusive
in one sentence why is it so hard
because we have yet to make the delivery
system be a 21st century delivery system
it's left over from the past it's fret
it's like the 19th century cottage
industry of England it's fragmented
doctors scattered around the community
hospitals in every town is paid on a
piecemeal fee-for-service basis the
technology is a 20th century technology
all the modern things could be done it's
not an American healthcare today it's
got to change thank you thank you thank
you dr. pearl you so much